nous ne sommes pas venus jusqu'ici pour
voir une bouteille de soda abandonnée
après un pique-nique mais pour un
phénomène bien plus insidieux
[Musique]
en fait toutes ces petites bises c'est
ce qu'on appelle les granulés de
plastique industriels
on regarde autour on voit que ça c'est
super galère à récolter
si entre les doigts c'est tout petit le
ciel de Montréal bouché par un épée
brouillard blanc de l'autre côté du
fleuve Saint-Laurent la rive est à peine
visible un phénomène que nous
connaîtrons dans une moindre mesure dans
les heures qui viennent en France le
panache de fumée Canadien devrait
bientôt atteindre l'Irlande le
Royaume-Uni et chez nous le golfe de
Gascogne depuis plusieurs semaines des
incendies gigantesques ravages le Canada
provoquant d'importantes fumées au
Québec les fumées engloutissent Montréal
qui battent aujourd'hui un triste record
celui de la ville la plus polluée au
monde ça se colle au sable quand on voit
ça un peu de loin on pourrait penser que
c'est un grain de sable ou un petit
caillou mais c'est tout à fait ça en
fait ça se confond vraiment avec le
sable ça peut aussi se confondre avec
des œufs par exemple de batraciens ou
quoi les oiseaux et les poissons
ingèrent ces granulés là
certains leur ont même donné un joli
petit nom les larmes de sirène très
poétiques Marion Cotillard trouve que la
liste des violences policières et de ce
fait gouvernemental contre les
mouvements écologistes donnent le
vertige et la nausée elle parle de
dérive sécuritaire et regrette la
dissolution du collectif les
soulèvements de la terre j'invite madame
Cotillard à regarder des images de
sainte Soline les policiers pris pour
cible les policiers incendiés caillassés
canardésera
la porte
je me suis retrouvé un jour en Belgique
à traverser hors des clous voilà c'est
pas bien grave mais en Belgique c'est
grave et pas de bol pour
bien loin et ils m'ont arrêté ils m'ont
dit ah mais madame à quoi ça sert de
mettre le petit bonhomme en mousse
un peu rebelle un peu parisienne je leur
ai dit non mais attendez ça va il y
avait personne j'ai juste traversé j'ai
passé quelque chose et Ben et ben toute
toute méchante parisienne que je suis
ils m'ont pris au colback et ils m'ont
emmené jusqu'au jusqu'au camion pour que
je paye dans le camion personne le dit
ne le dira comme ça mais au fond madame
Cotillard qui ne vit plus en France mais
à Los Angeles ne connaît rien à rien à
ces sujets elle regarde ça de loin dans
son existence 5 étoiles entre deux
tournages à Hollywood et une publicité
pour Chanel j'en ai assez de ces
personnalités qui s'achètent des brevets
de bonne conscience et qui vivent à
l'opposé de ce qu'elle dénonce s'il
semble être un sportif ordinaire
l'ex-corterback des commanders de
Washington Carson Welles à partager sur
son compte une toute autre passion les
clichés de sa partie de chasse ce
week-end tout sourire derrière la
dépouille de l'animal qu'il venait
d'abattre incroyable selon lui mais si
la chasse à l'ours noir est légale en
Alaska tant que le règlement est
respecté l'indignation ne s'est pas fait
attendre du côté des internautes madame
Cotillard est une actrice une actrice ou
un acteur ça joue elle joue l'indignée
elle joue la rebelle elle joue la
révolté elle est une caricature personne
n'est dupe sauf elle évidemment
regarde sur la branche de l'arbre là ça
s'est déposé
il y en a partout
[Musique]
une industriel du plastique qui nous a
dit mais tu sais c'est comme ça un
gâteau en fait tu perds toujours un peu
de farine bah là c'est la même chose
avec les granulés
à quel point le problème est pris en
considération ils ont repris tous les
sondages disponibles depuis 1949
regardez plus de 600 000 personnes dans
60 pays et on tombe toujours et à chaque
époque autour de 85% de personnes qui
pensent donc c'était mieux avant la
faute nouvelle génération
oh là là là
[Rires]
[Musique]
chaque année en Europe jusqu'à 160 000
tonnes de granulés sont dispersés dans
la nature selon une estimation de la
Commission européenne 160
000 tonnes c'est le poids de 16 fois la
Tour Eiffel cette femme s'appelle Jean
Barry sa fille Mégane à 15 ans et selon
sa maman elle se bat contre une tumeur
au cerveau comme beaucoup d'ados Mégane
et fans de Disney alors avec Jean elles
font de Billy vin Magic une association
pour exaucer les vœux des enfants
cancéreux et notamment visiter
Disneyland et c'est le triomphe believe
in magic récolte des centaines de
milliers d'euros de dons pour faire
rêver les enfants grâce à Jean et Meghan
des petits malades participent par
exemple à la soirée de Noël de
Buckingham Palace Jérôme vous rappelez
de John Baez qui a quand même rendu
visite à cette dame Jérôme
je me souviens de la
annonce une rechute Mégane doit partir
suivre une thérapie à plus de 100.000
euros les dons affluent tout de suite en
deux jours la somme est atteinte mais la
tumeur s'est étendue des pleurs Jean
avant de demander plus de fond certains
donateurs commencent à tickets Jean ne
mentionne ni médecin ni hôpital alors
ils enquêtes et ils découvrent le poteau
rose en réalité Jeanne et Meghan vivent
dans l'hôtel 5 étoiles de Disney World
aux États-Unis et Meghan loin d'être en
réanimation profite du voyage selon un
détective privé la musique
c'est
excessivement connu oui ça fait l'objet
d'un film c'est une bande originale
bonne chance il découvre les croisières
les hôtels de luxe et surprise il manque
des dizaines de milliers d'euros dans
les caisses de l'association
malheureusement Mégane perd subitement
la vie à 23 ans mais pas du tumeur au
cerveau elle meurt à cause d'un foie
trop gras selon ses sœurs et un rapport
hospitalier le concert aurait été
inventé toute pièce par leur mère Jean
elle n'a jamais été poursuivie l'enquête
s'est arrêté après le décès de Mégane
c'est une musique de Ennio Morricone
[Rires]
pour les petits c'est hamac et pour eux
aussi la soirée commence bien nous on
est venu s'amuser
qu'elle a les boissons oui c'est ça pas
tout le gratin de reconquête était
présent
alors au revoir